all right what's up
everybody it is march 2nd
2021 and it is a stupid day full of
stupid people doing stupid things but
not you guys because you're watching the
reuben report direct message with me
your host dave rubin there is a lot
going on here we uh we were planning on
four
stories today you guys know i like to do
usually three
sometimes four if i think uh you know
there's some more stuff happening
today we're doing five because just in
the last few minutes
all hell has broken loose related
to dr seuss that rhyme that completely
was not intentional all hell has broken
loose
related to dr seuss was not intentional
um yeah we're banning dr seuss books and
i have to cover this
and we busted out my own copy i i keep
a whole bunch of dr seuss books in the
garage
we knew obviously for years that they
would be coming for dr seuss so i keep
all of my dangerous
books in the garage i have a stack of
mineconf and then that's right next to a
stack of don't burn this book and then
it's all
of dr seuss's 39 books uh six of which
will no longer be published anymore i
cannot believe it
but the most dangerous one is right here
it's oh the places you'll go
which you know for years and years for
decades this book
this very short thin book of rhymes
was given to high school graduates and
college graduates usually college
graduates
as a a fun way of sending them off into
the world oh the places you'll go the
things that you'll do
and upon re-reading this today after i
moved
the pile of mine comp moved the pile of
don't burn this book
grab this re-read it i think this might
be the most dangerous but just to be
clear
as to what's happening here people the
company
that publishes dr seuss books and
there's at least 39 of them
there may be more we'll find out if he
had more racist stuff you know hidden
away
in in the back room or something they
have said that they are no longer going
to
sell six of his titles and i've got all
six of them for you here
scary titles each one of them 1937's
mulberry street nano getting rid of that
one
in 1947 he published mick elgat's
pool we're getting rid of that mick
elegance pool i suppose that is
1950s if i ran the zoo you can only
imagine what racist stuff was happening
there over at the zoo
uh 1953 he had scrambled egg
super where did the eggs come from who
what how many villages did you have to
destroy to get those eggs
this one is fairly obvious why they had
to get rid of it
1955's on beyond zebra
you can imagine with the black and the
white with the zebra something something
wasn't right
and of course in 1976 his truly racist
manifesto
the cats quizzer these will no longer
be published by random house children's
books
anymore uh because you know
tolerance and stuff because we're
becoming so evolved
in 2021 that we're erasing books of
1937.
duh right like i mean it's obviously
happening but anyway so i go into the
the garage there where i keep all of our
sensitive racist books all of the other
racist things in the past that i have i
also have on dvd the golden girls
episode
when uh
when blanche and rose are caught with
mud masks on which appear to make them
look black
that episode has now been taken off hulu
yes i am not making this up now
ironically
the episode is about how dorothy's son a
white boy is marrying a black woman and
the two families come together
but uh but a white boy and a
and a black girl marrying that's against
woke orthodoxy of the future
because uh you understand that
segregation will be cool again according
to the woke people we're gonna have to
be separate but equal and not really
equal too uh but that's a slightly
different topic uh anyway so i went into
the uh
into the storage room there and i busted
out all the places you'll go because i
thought well wait a minute if these are
the six
books that they're banning the six seuss
books there's got to be others he wrote
39 did he just get all the racist stuff
out
with the zoo and the and the zebra and
the eggs and the cat
there must be some other stuff so i
quickly read through this this morning
with my team and i'm only going to read
a couple pages for you here but this
i would argue dr seuss's oh the places
you'll go
that this is dr seuss's most dangerous
book i'll read three pages to you
okay congratulations
today is your day you're off to great
places
you're off and away
you have brains in your head you have
feet
in your shoes you can steer yourself
any direction you choose you're on your
own
and you know what you know and you are
the guy
who'll decide where to go
you'll look up and down streets look i'm
over with care
about some you will say i don't choose
to go there
with your head full of brains and your
shoes full of feet you're too smart to
go down
any not so good street and you may
not find any you'll want to go down
in that case of course you'll head
straight
out of town and it goes on and on
with this self-empowerment and that is
just i mean
you know for the woksters for the
constant victim class for those
who love social justice and
intersectionality
and critical race theory and all of
these things you can't have people
you got brains in your head you got feet
in your shoes this is
the most dangerous book dr
seuss ever put out you can't have people
thinking they can make choices for
themselves
you can't have people thinking that they
have capacity over their minds and they
can just get
out in the world and do whatever they
want you have this book
this must be banned so please
dr seuss publishers sure you got rid of
the cats quizzer and they were it was
problematic nobody's denying what that
cat was up to
uh oh beyond zebra you know okay fine
but this is the one
okay this is scary stuff this is about
individualism
this is about freedom this is about
going to get
what's yours and we we've you know that
just can't this is 2021 okay
this isn't you know 1941 okay when you
could just go out there and do what you
want
in our new woke society
our safe and secure society we must
eliminate books like this
you know this thing is how many pages
here you've got uh
oh it doesn't even have page numbers it
doesn't even have page numbers so you
guys would like that you wokesters
because i know you guys don't like math
so there's no page numbers on this thing
anyway he gets on a whole adventure
and figures out that he's got to do it
on his own and whoo
lori lori all right let's talk about
canada people um
the canada's got some problems you know
we oft joke about canada oh they're
above us they're up to the north and
they're
very pleasant and they've got a lot of
room there's not a lot of people and
it's a big country and they say a a lot
and they like poutine
and things of that nature but they've
got some problems up there
mostly related to their absolutely
ridiculous prime minister justin trudeau
but it's actually getting worse on the
quarantine front right now even
as you guys know i interviewed jordan
peterson this week and by the way
his second his third book i should say
beyond order
uh comes out today and if you have not
seen our full two-hour interview it's up
on youtube right now
um but i wanted to fly to canada to
interview him but they've got crazy
quarantine
situations there it's worse in different
provinces it sounds like montreal is
particularly bad
but they have put out some new
recommendations that are crazy so this
comes from peel medical
up in canada and the toronto sun wrote a
piece on this i mean
this is just absolutely bananas so
according to the toronto sun
peel health has issued guidelines to
parents instructing them to keep any
children
who have been sent home because a
classmate has tested positive for
covid19
isolated in a separate room from all
other family members for 14 days
the severe guidelines which apply even
to small children who are dismissed from
child care
are being criticized by experts as
harmful
and not supported by science okay so
we've got a what to do
chart uh before i dive into the chart
specifically i mean just
take a look at the chart but the basic
idea here guys that you're going to have
young children so let's say you've got a
five-year-old in kindergarten
and someone in their class gets coveted
and then you're going to start
isolating children for 14 days away from
the members of their family
in essence they're telling people to
lock them in their bedroom basically
leave
food by the door imagine the level of
psychological
damage you are going to do to these
children who believes
any of these people that are supposedly
the experts
at this point as they destroy our
families as they destroy our
jobs and everything else man we have a
lot of work to do so
let's look at the image here because
it's it's quite bananas
the child must isolate must self-isolate
which means stay in a separate bedroom
eat in a separate room apart from others
use a separate bathroom if possible
if the child must leave their room they
should wear a mask and stay two meters
apart from others
it is strongly recommended to test
recovery 19 on or after the date listed
in your letter
and then any other children who live at
the same address should stay home
from school or child care until their
child who is who is close contact
returns to school or child care
do not need to self-isolate in a
separate room so that's nice so if your
brother
has coveted you don't have to
self-isolate in another room you're free
to roam around the domicile
uh they should not go out to play with
friends or see anyone
who don't or live with you so if your
brother's got it
you can't play with anyone else these
are sane people insane recommendations
adults living at the same address can go
to work unless their child develops
symptoms
or tests positive i'm not sure how that
makes sense because i thought we were
always watching out for asymptomatic
spread as well uh should check for
covenant symptoms for everyone in the
household every day
healthcare workers should check with
their employer about their
organizational policy
this is completely insane and i like
canada
i love touring in canada with jordan
peterson we did about
20 different shows in canada in
different cities a couple of them we
went back to
twice one of the one of my favorite
cities in the world and two of our best
shows were in
in calgary and western canada i love
toronto as well
but this is completely bananas and we
are watching
authoritarian governments just move on
people and i guess at the end of the day
no one's gonna do anything right like no
one like if you're a parent and you
listen to these
regulations you're an idiot and and
you're in some essence you're a child
abuser
as well you're gonna lock your child in
a room for 14 days in your ass how about
this
how about this call me crazy call me
crazy and again i'm not a parent yet
so i can't give perfect parenting advice
but perhaps if you're a parent and your
child gets sick
you'll know what to do within your house
you don't have to lock the child
in the basement and throw them fish
heads once a week maybe that's not the
best way to do it maybe
you would know to keep them separate for
a couple days maybe
you would let them come downstairs every
now and again or be in a
main room or you'd have other people
wearing masks in the house but you'd
kind of figure it out for yourself
but no peel medical they're going to
figure it out for you
with their ridiculous chart because
they're better than you
and you love orders because you're a
good citizen
guys let's talk about expressvpn
you know if you supported trump and
watched him uh or watched how big tech
tried to shut him down
it's reasonable to think that any of us
might be next
the locusts are like religious zealots
who continue their
crusade of censorship repression and
cancel culture until every last voice of
repression
has been crushed see you later dr seuss
sadly they've been reinforced by the
media and some of the largest companies
in the world that's right big tech in
the far left
have formed an unholy alliance to track
censor and spy on us
their fellow americans there has never
been a more important time to protect
our internet activity from bad actors
and that's why i urge you guys to get
expressvpn everything you search for
watch or click online can be tracked by
big tech companies
they can then match your activity to
your true identity using your device's
unique ip address
when i switch on expressvpn with my
computer or phone my ip address is
masked
by a secure vpn server which makes it
harder for websites to identify me the
expressvpn app also encrypts my network
data to protect my sensitive information
from being compromised plus you can use
expressvpn on up to five devices
simultaneously so your whole family can
stay safe with a single subscription
that's what i like or what i like most
is how easy it is to use it just takes
one click to protect all your devices
you literally click one button it turns
green you're good to go
that's why they're rated number one as
far as vpn by cnet
and wired so stop handing over your data
to big tech companies and their far left
enablers in government
defend your rights with the vpni trust
for online protection visit
expressvpn.com
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n
dot com slash reuben to get three months
for absolutely free go to expressvpn.com
reuben to learn more and now back to me
all right so if you thought that our
first two stories about
eliminating children's books that we all
know nothing's wrong with and
burning books in the modern day if you
think that wasn't stupid
and you think that locking your children
into in a bedroom for 14 days
isn't stupid well meet the joe biden
white house
because this is the department of
homeland secretary alejandro
mayorkas during a white house press
conference yesterday
discussing illegal immigration and i
don't want to color your opinion of it
you take a look
we are progressing every single day i
don't have a particular timeline
but all i can do is communicate both to
the american public
and to the individual seeking protection
that we are working around the clock
seven days a week to make that time
frame as short as possible
but they need to wait but they need to
wait with a particular goal in mind
we are not saying don't come we are
saying don't come
now because we will be able to deliver
a safe and orderly process to them
as quickly as possible let me read that
quote for you in case you missed it
there from mr alejandro he said we are
not saying
don't come we are saying don't come now
because we'll be able to deliver a safe
and orderly process to them as quickly
as possible now look
i want to be very clear about something
and i look forward to media matters and
the other
twitter losers selectively editing this
video
we are a nation of immigrants virtually
everyone that lives in the united states
either is an immigrant themselves or the
descendants of immigrants there are very
few
exceptions to that the exceptions would
be native american people
and peoples who whose ancestors were
brought here by slavery
okay those are really the only two
exceptions everyone else whatever your
religious background is ethnic
background national origin
etc etc came here and pretty much
pretty much almost without exclusion
came here with absolutely nothing i want
you person watching this right now think
about
your grandparents or your great
grandparents whoever it is in your
family
uh that came here did they come here
with anything probably not because
everyone came here for a better life
that's still why these very people that
he's talking about want to come to
america
for how how wacky it is it's still
better than pretty much everywhere else
at least for now although that window is
definitely getting shorter the point
here is that we are a nation of
immigrants and that's something to be
deeply proud of
and what we did was create this
incredible melting pot where everyone
could come here with all the traditions
and i talk about this all the time
all their history and family foods and
all of these things
and fold into the melting pot of america
that is in stark contrast to what
happened in most of europe
which created multicultural societies
where there were stark
differences by where you came from
into your new country so whether it's
the uk
or it's germany or other european
countries if you came from
a different place with a different
background or a different skin color you
didn't
integrate into society in the way that
you did in america not in every case but
but in most cases actually that's how it
is versus america
where everyone gets to be part of the
dream
right and and asian americans succeed at
the highest levels here
no one gave asian americans anything
right and we've had a black president
already most european countries haven't
had
a black prime minister yet etc etc we
all know that we've done it really well
here
so we are a nation of immigrants that's
something to be very proud of but we got
serious serious problems right now
we are focused right now on getting rid
of blanche and rose in the golden girls
and taking out dr
seuss and lockdowns and
complete misinformation and a meltdown
by our
mainstream media we have massive massive
massive problems
and the idea that we would be saying to
illegal immigrants
yeah yeah still come still come just
wait we're going to take care of we need
to sort all this stuff out it's like
maybe we need to take care of our house
at the moment i'm not sitting here
saying we need to shut down immigration
period i'm not saying that no one can
come here
for asylum and anything else but why is
it so
obvious if you're paying attention that
this administration
and and certainly it's it's woke
progressive base cares far more about
illegal
immigrants and people who want to become
americans than people who are americans
that does not make me a right-wing crazy
maniac i am
for america i am for the plurality of
america and as many people coming here
as is possible but
but right now does america like think
about it if you were
if you were if america is a home let's
just say america is our home right and
it is our home
well if you were sort of having all
sorts of internal problems at home the
parents were fighting
there's a drug addict downstairs the
heat doesn't work
like all sorts of problems what would be
the best thing to do would you just let
a gajillion other people in there
because you're really really nice
and you want to just be really be nice
to people although it's not really
because they want to be nice to people
it's because they want new voters on the
democratic side obviously but would
would it be that you just let everybody
in you just open up the door hey guys
come on in sure there's no heat there's
no running water
a little disease here they're they're
fighting you know he's got a gun we got
big problems it's very abusive
or would you say hey we got to take care
of our house first we got to
clean our room we got to get things in
order here and then we can talk about
all that
but that's not what they're going to do
they are going to make it very clear i
mean he's
he's not just signaling it to people
that want to come here he's flat out
saying it
we're not saying don't come we're saying
don't come now
but you know what if you do come now
we'll probably let you in because we're
a bunch of
oddly guild guilt-ridden weirdos and and
that's what we're gonna do
anyway i i wanted to play this clip
because i think it's worth noting
that there is you're gonna see and this
is my suspicion and i i'm pretty
sure this will will bear itself out over
the next three years
you will see no position taken by this
administration that would be thought of
as a pro-american
position meaning sure we're going to get
into wars and we're going to blow up
people in the middle east again
and things like that but we are not
going to do which by the way is not a
pro-american position i was being
sarcastic
um we are not going to do anything that
is for the american people first meaning
strengthen the american worker build the
middle class
cut taxes on people get the government
out of the way open up
the states all of these things we're
gonna have to fight for it as citizens
but
it ain't coming from the administration
and uh that is
that is a deeply depressing thought but
i i'm pretty confident that that's
how it's going to be uh let's talk about
race because we don't talk about race
enough sure
we've banned six dr seuss books and that
will
help get rid of racism much like getting
aunt jemima
off the uh syrup bottle that did you
know if you've got a hundred if america
was 100
racist last year you know you take out
jemima
now i'd say you're 90 racist get rid of
uncle ben
that's about five percent jemima was
bigger than ben no pun intended
uh you're at 85 percent you you take out
dr
seuss i don't know i'll give dr seuss 15
a lot of books big breath of work right
so now you're
you're in your 60s your 70s oh lordy
lordy well
when i talk about the administration and
and how they they constantly have their
eye
off the ball because they're obsessed
with equity instead of what actually is
happening and by the way my friend peter
bogosian who's been on the show many
times who's assistant professor of
philosophy up at
portland state university one of the
things he often talks about
is once any organization allows
the ideas of social justice into the
organization
it will no longer do its prime objective
as cleanly
or as well in other words if you're a
company
and you make pens your goal should be to
make the best pen possible sell as many
pens and all that
once you let the ideas of social justice
in and say oh we're not going to hire
the best people who know about marketing
a pen we're going to do it based on the
color of skin or we're not going to hire
the best people
who know how to build a pen or actually
make ink that's cheaper or blah blah
once you start
focusing putting your resources on
something other than the objective which
is to sell the pen
you're going to slowly destroy your
company and that goes for
journalistic institutions that goes for
governmental institutions and everything
else now the reason i mention all of
this
is because there was a tweet yesterday
from anne-marie
slaughter and uh actually let's pull up
anne-marie slaughter's twitter bio first
yeah let's do her twitter bio first
she's a patriot she's an entrepreneur i
know most of you haven't heard of her
that's why i'm reading this
she's a mother and she's a mentor okay
pretty good she's a thinker all right
not bad i like what's happening here
then she's a feminist okay if your first
wave i'm good with you
she's the ceo of a place called new
america and here's where it gets
interesting
she's a former harvard professor a
harvard law professor
that's pretty powerful she's the former
princeton dean
the dean of princeton people and she's
also the director of policy planning
at the state department okay now we can
come back to me so this is this is a big
woman
all right this is somebody i mean
harvard princeton
state department this is someone who's
well educated she's obviously got the
good ideas and i assume she's doing good
at the state department let's look at
her tweet from yesterday
she writes this is essential but it's
not just that without racial equity at
home
we cannot be effective abroad why not
start imagining what a foreign policy
with racial equity at its core
would look like and what she's referring
to is the tweet you're seeing below
there
which is a quote from joe biden there is
no longer a bright line between
foreign and domestic policy and to push
back against authoritarianism
effectively the u.s must make racial
equity
a whole government effort now
what can somebody explain to me
what racial equity has to do with
foreign policy
should we be looking around the world
and going well
you know if we killed a couple europeans
we should probably kill a couple
africans
and if we killed a couple women here we
should probably blow up a couple women
over here
the idea of equity is ridiculous
it is the most dangerous idea flowing
through society
the idea that your foreign policy would
be based on equity i mean it just
doesn't even make any sense
like it's not comparing apples and
oranges at least they're both fruits the
idea of equity in foreign policy foreign
policy
what what would a sensible foreign
policy look like i actually lay it out
in don't burn this book
a sensible foreign policy i'm for a
strong military so that you don't have
people messing with you not so that
you're invading countries not so that
you're bombing everybody
you have a strong military so you say
hey guys don't don't do anything because
we're gonna smack you
pretty hard by the way we had pretty
pretty solid four years of that
under under orange man now
what would equity mean in foreign policy
what does that mean that if we bomb a
little bit over here we better bomb a
little bit over here
that we have to our foreign policy that
we have to have x amount
of this color person represented and
this gender person and this sexuality
none of it makes any sense but they say
i mean this is a woman who was the dean
at princeton
a harvard law professor and let me just
read the quote again let's pull it up
just one more time
just the level of stupidity like it's
just meaningless drivel
that they put out there as if it means
something this
is essential but it's not just that
without racial equity at home we cannot
be effective abroad
why not start imagining what a foreign
policy with racial equity at its core
would look like what
what could you possibly mean by foreign
policy should have racial equity at its
core
and by the way without racial equity at
home not racial equality like that
martin luther king guy wanted
and they'll get him like dr seuss soon
enough they're going for the doctors now
first you take out seuss then you take
out mlk jr okay
um it does you want racial equality
not racial equity
we got work to do people we got work to
do again this is someone
who this isn't like the reason i want to
do this tweet it doesn't matter that
you've probably never heard of her i
mean this is
someone who works in the state
department who is a blue check twitter
person who was the dean of princeton
who is a former professor of
law at harvard and then they string
together and this is why social justice
makes so many people so
stupid they string together these words
as if it means anything
just one more time racial equity should
be at the core of our foreign policy
really think about that and do let me
know in the youtube comments what racial
equity at the core
of our foreign policy could possibly
mean it means absolutely nothing but not
only does it mean nothing
the previous part of her sentence racial
equity at home
you can't have racial equity you can
have racial equality
which is what we have if you were to
show me that there was a law in place
that
segregated or punished a certain type of
person based on the color of their skin
i would be against that law
we used to have those types of laws we
don't have those types of laws anymore
the idea of racial equity is that we're
going to use the power of the state to
rejigger
the society and the economy and by the
way what's that you want to really go
down that road you guys really want to
do that well
the end result of this of this new move
on equity
is that we will have systemic racism we
will have institutionalized racism
and it will be against white people they
these people will put
laws in place that will ensure that
white people will be punished and by the
way
at that harvard that harvard place that
she was a law professor
you all know this but they openly
discriminate against asian people
because
too many asians worked too hard and got
too educated not that people gave
asians anything right were there were
there a ton of asian people that came
here with anything a lot of
a lot of my korean friends their their
grandparents came over with a lot no
complete nonsense complete nonsense it's
not just asian it's japanese chinese
whatever it might be
okay but this is what they're pushing on
us and just wait till
they're the ones the people who scream
about systemic racism
while it doesn't exist in the system
although it does exist
racism as a thing it's part of the human
condition
and we should do our best to eliminate
it they are the ones that are going to
be putting racism in the system but if
you thought
that the stories that i've done thus far
weren't stupid enough
i want to talk to you about andrew and
chris cuomo the cuomo brothers
one of whom is a cnn anchor and one of
whom
who is the governor of new york although
perhaps for not
much longer because as you've probably
heard over the last couple of days
there have been a couple scandals
brewing where andrew cuomo the governor
of new york
has been accused of sexual harassment
now i'm not even going to comment on the
veracity
of the claims that that is for people to
discover
what's true and what's not true i know
we were supposed to believe all women
before
and me too and all that whole thing and
then it was like oh
believe women if they're accusing
republicans like brett kavanaugh but
don't believe them if they're accusing
democrats and it's all very weird
but in any event andrew cuomo is being
accused i think now by three women of
some level of sexual harassment
and his brother chris cuomo who has
interviewed him
countless times and done ridiculous
silly
comedy skits with giant cotton swabs on
cnn well his brother addressed
andrew's the accusations against andrew
on his cnn show last night and
let's take a look before we start
tonight uh let me say something that i'm
sure is
very obvious to you who watched my show
and thank you
for that you're straight with me i'll be
straight with you
obviously i'm aware of what's going on
with my brother
and obviously i cannot cover it because
he is my brother now of course
cnn has to cover it they have covered it
extensively
and they will continue to do so
i have always cared very deeply
about these issues and profoundly so
i just wanted to tell you that there's a
lot of news going on that matters
also so let's get after
all right so look chris cuomo is just a
ridiculous clown
in a cnn little tv box that's all that
he is
not only did he report on stories about
his brother and about covet and the
economy and everything else that his
brother's done for the last year
but he interviewed him many many times i
mean if you haven't seen it they did
this
absolutely ridiculous interview at the
height of the pandemic where
where chris busts out this giant cotton
swab and they're laughing about things
while supposedly people are dying
everywhere this is the worst
pandemic in the history of the world and
everything else but now
he can't talk about his brother anymore
so
okay was there a conflict of interest
and were you ignoring it before
or was there never a conflict of
interest but now you don't want to throw
your brother under the bus
but this is just completely consistent
with the sort of insider nonsense
that is mainstream media and politicians
half of the people on these networks
that are your news anchors that are
supposedly bringing you truth
half of them worked for the
administrations much like george
stephanopoulos
who i think was chief of staff in the
clinton administration do you think
you're getting really honest information
from abc's chief white house
correspondent or whatever he is chief of
news uh
you know when he worked for the uh with
the clinton administration and there's a
million other examples of this people go
into politics
they usually fail there or they screw
things up and then they get jobs as
cable news anchors this one's
a particularly sort of perverse gross
incestuous version of it
because it's like for this last year
there were all the
all the sycophants all the blue czech
sycophants who were like it's so
cute watching chris cuomo and andrew
cuomo talk to each other during that so
cute and they're both handsome and who's
cuter and
and it's like well now that the [ __ ] has
hit the fan now that andrew's in trouble
now
whoa lemon you're gonna have to talk
about that
acosta you're gonna have to talk about
that i can't talk about that when it was
looking pretty good for him
before the whole scandal blew up and you
know he killed all those people by
putting them back into old age rooms
then i can talk to him and joke
with him during the pandemic but not not
anymore anyway i think
you see my point people uh as i promised
yesterday this is a big week so if you
have not
seen it yet my full two hour interview
with jordan peterson who is returning
and dare i say just in the nick of time
uh it is now up on youtube as always it
is up totally ad free at
reubenreport.locals.com
and people you're not going to believe
this
i am going to meet real
live human beings tonight
at an undisclosed location members of
the reuben report community will be
coordinating we are going
to a bar together we're going to have
drinks
we might have chicken wings something
that andrew cuomo once said doesn't
count as a meal
we'll decide we'll decide tonight uh at
two o'clock today i will be posting the
location for members only
at reubenreport.locals.com i know that a
whole bunch of people
are coming already we're gonna meet at
six o'clock tonight here in
los angeles that's two o'clock pacific
i'll be posting the location again
that's members only
uh and then we'll be meeting at six
o'clock and i'll i'll hang out till till
we've all
shook hands and cheered and uh and clank
glasses and all that good stuff so i
look forward to actually seeing real
human beings it's a beautiful day
in los angeles we'll we'll hang out
outside because it's highly illegal to
be indoors with other
humans uh and uh and again
jordan peterson interview la meetup
today room report.logos.com
and whatever you do whatever you do
do not buy this book okay
hitler hitler the leader
of the nazis wrote a book once okay
it's called mind comp my struggle and
that's a dangerous book
but this i mean i read the first three
pages for you guys just at the top of
the show
the self-empowerment of this book the
idea that you should go out and get
yours the idea
that the world is yours to conquer that
it's your oyster and you've got a chance
because you've got a brain in your head
and feet in your shoes that is the most
dangerous idea out there so get
this book a minute ago i said don't get
it but what i really mean
is get this book get this book really
quick before they take this away because
this is far more dangerous
than the zebra book or the cat book or
the other books
that you can do it on your own that's
what i believe i hope that's what you
believe
have a good day i look forward to seeing
you guys tonight later